hello and welcome back to dead talks
this is a video that I came up with the
idea for when I was doing my things you
missed episodes on split and unbreakable
and I was watching both movies and
noticing that they're very similar
scenes at similar points in each movie
like for example both movies began with
a birthday party scene I mean not a
party in Elijah's case but both movies
open with a birthday scene and then
there's a scene of a child pointing a
gun at an older family member at about
the same point in both movies right
before the climax so I figured I'd watch
the movies side-by-side and see like
what other clues were left by director M
night Shyamalan to tell us that split is
a sequel and how it uses that same
formula as unbreakable so there are a
couple different ways I could do this I
can do it like this where I just play
both movies at regular speed and split
is a little bit of a longer movie so
it'll go a little bit past unbreakable
and the other way would be to stretch
them both so that they're the same
length like this and that might help
things line up a little bit better
because they I mean both movies use like
you have to react structure formula so
similar events are gonna be happening at
the same points in each movie but for
this for this video I'm gonna be doing
it to where they are just both playing
at regular speed so with that all being
said let's watch split and unbreakable
so I don't actually think that things
are gonna line up perfectly I don't
think he planned to have things line up
exactly if you put both movies on top of
each other like this I don't think he
edited split over unbreakable I think if
you had done something like that then
split probably would have suffered for
it but I do think that there are just
certain similarities with the plot of
each movie see see we got Elijah being
born and Claire celebrating her birthday
yeah those two in the back seat are
watching Suzie's world videos I got to
say this sounds pretty good with the
unbreakable music playing over this
beginning scene and split oh this is
gonna be so cool okay I think when Bruce
Willis comes on-screen he's gonna have
his head against the window just like
very similar to about how Dennis is
sitting against the window and split
that's like they're both leaning back on
the headrest like that that's really
interesting and again there may be
things that we find that are kind of
coincidentally similar but I think this
is this is pretty similar I'd have to
say so these aren't lining up perfectly
but another thing that's similar about
both of these movies is you have the
main character waking up and realizing
that they're OK after some kind of
disaster in the case to split it's her
getting knocked out by Dennis and waking
up in the holding room and then in the
case of unbreakable he wakes up in the
doctor's office after the train accident
and if that might be one of those things
that if we stretched the movies to be
the same length that they maybe even
fall a little bit closer to each other I
do hope that there is something at some
point where like there's an exact frame
in both movies that looks very similar
it's what I can use it for my thumbnail
but I can just have like oh like a
shocked reaction man watching him side
by side like this makes it look like
twice as tense twice as scary oh this is
so interesting okay seeing the news
report of both tragedies on the screen
in unbreakable it's Joseph and now right
here it's dr. Fletcher they don't take
place at exactly the same time but they
take place at very similar points in
each movie and I think maybe if you
count the scenes or sequences then those
events do kind of line up in terms of
their overall position and that's very
much a coincidence but Barry and David
being on the stairs at the same time
that's hilarious they're trying to hear
both trying to hear the audio from both
me was that once reminds me of that time
that I watched every West Dakota video
at once that's weird
as soon as she says if ever something
would have happened to me he opens the
thing and says how many days have you
been sick but again that's not the type
of thing that I'm looking for
necessarily with this video two old
ladies on the screen at the same time oh
my god that is almost like too close
though
David standing in the doorway talking
said this woman and Barry aka Dennis is
standing in the doorway talking to
doctor Fletcher they leave at the same
time are you kidding me are you kidding
me this is already more interesting than
I thought this is the same shot this is
insane
they're both looking like through the
door in profile at the same time that's
crazy I'm so glad I did this this is so
entertaining
it's the same shot are you kidding me
how does that keep happening like both
looking down at the same angle and both
over the shoulders oh this is kind of
interesting
so in split we're seeing Hedwig's
drawing of the beast and in unbreakable
we're seeing Elijah open up the comic
book and if you saw my things you missed
you know that yellow guy in the comic
book page jaguaro is very similar to the
beast and I think he represents what the
beast is supposed to be in split and
also pretty interesting here is we have
that upside down shot of Elijah flipping
around the comic and then the sideways
shot over there of Casey first viewing
Hedwig when she wakes up there's another
thing that I talked about in the things
you miss so if you want to hear about
like what all that means the upside down
shots the sideways shots in both movies
go and check out those two things you
missed episodes a couple of scenes after
this Elijah talks about how comics are
like the lack our last link to
hieroglyphics and drawings and runes and
stuff and I wonder if
is kind of like an emerging comic-book
artist in a way with his pictures his
drawings of the beasts and stuff like
that there is a top-down scene like this
that scene in split right now later in
the movie when David is looking back at
his old newspaper clippings in the
closet it's kind of a similar shot yeah
this is the scene I was talking about
where we're above David and to be honest
in both movies when this shot is used
it's because of something secret hidden
above in splits case it's the secret
passageway through the vent and then
David is hiding his gun up there and his
old newspaper clippings this is kind of
interesting I was a little bit hesitant
to bring it up but dr. Fletcher has a
suspicion that this is not Barry
but he's hiding something right now
David has a suspicion that that guy in
the camouflage jacket is carrying a gun
that he's hiding something and then
we've got Elijah saying like do you have
good instincts for things like that and
dr. Fletcher on the other side using her
intuition to make the prediction that
this is in fact Dennis not Barry
so now Elijah is keeping an eye on this
guy as he's leaving and trying to gather
more information and dr. Fletcher on the
other side is looking at the security
footage of Dennis leaving and trying to
gather more information this is another
thing I thought about and I didn't
mention in the things you missed
episodes but Shyamalan makes a cameo in
both movies so is he playing the same
character in both movies did the stadium
drug dealer guy grow up and become an IT
guy in split know that there's my
thumbnail both characters suffering both
characters lying down at this point in
the movie both characters have basically
given up hope right here so this is the
shem wan cameo scene in unbreakable and
earlier I was talking about like is this
the same character is the Schemmel on
from split looking at it like he does
make an effort to make himself look
different but also he's 15 years older
in split so obviously he's going to look
different but as far as like the hair
style he didn't really try to replicate
the look
I'm unbreakable so that I'm kind of
thinking that it's not the same
character it's kind of also interesting
how a dr. Fletcher's color is also green
as Davises and she has like all of these
plans in the background Schemmel on
recently posted a tweet where he talks
about like the reasoning for all of his
color choices in unbreakable and he
talked about Green being like the color
of nature and the color of healing and
that's what I chose green for the good
guy it seems like every time an
unbreakable that David talks to an old
lady happens to be during these dr.
fletcher scenes i mean these two scenes
are very similar this is gonna be such a
bad juxtaposition the funniest Barden
split going over the most serious part
in unbreakable and
this is kind of interesting there's two
characters facing each other talking in
profile
we have artwork in the back in both
situations and like these things may
have lined up unintentionally but he may
have had the idea for this scene based
on like I'm gonna compose this in a
similar way too and breakable when it
happened to line up
oh man here's another potentially really
cool reference or coincidence or
whatever you want to call it so she
contacts this guy on the walkie-talkie
and tells him to call the police and
this guy in the comic book store
threatens to call the police on Elijah
because he won't get out of the store
this is the only time that we see the
inside of Joseph's room I believe and
the only time in split that we see the
inside of Hedwig's room and they both
have toys in their room and stuff look
at this like he's guiding her down the
aisle and the atomic the guys is guiding
Elijah down the aisle and they're both
in trouble right they both noticed
something on the ground at the same time
this is unbelievable like when I made
this video I thought like okay there'll
be a couple things that are similar and
they might not even line up perfectly
but they're probably some scenes that
are similar in both movies but there are
so many crazy coincidences in this these
shots almost looks in like the rocks on
the right side and the trees on the left
side and they're both talking about a
game like the uncles talking about the
game where they pretend that they're
animals and she's talking about the game
where they ask each other questions you
know I didn't even think about this but
earlier in splits like and these don't
line up at all it was way earlier but
Casey says she tells how to wig like oh
we're like your babysitter's unbreakable
has this babysitter seen
I don't know why I brought that up but I
just thought that I would I always find
it hilarious how they don't even offer
the babysitter a ride it should just
supposed to walk home in the rain so I
think that Elijah revealing that kevin
has this weakness is also like
structurally kind of in the same place
as when dr. fletcher writes say his name
Kevin Wendell trauma on the receipt to
reveal the hoards weakness
I think the scenes are gonna get further
and further apart because we're getting
towards the end of the movie and as I
mentioned split is longer than
unbreakable so at the beginning they're
gonna be the similar scenes structurally
are gonna be kind of close we're at the
end they're gonna be a little bit
further apart but I do think that is
kind of a similar scene in both movies
and it's kind of a trope in superhero
movies in general where there's that
moment where the superhero his weakness
is exposed and he has to find a way to
overcome it and then of course there's
also this scene and unbreakable where
David is revisiting the train yard and
that's coming up pretty soon here and
split as well so there may be something
to be said about dr. Fletcher
discovering the horrible things that
Dennis and Patricia have done to these
girls taking place around the same time
as David going to the train station and
bumping into people and discovering like
all these horrible things that people
around the city have done and I think
that'll kind of come to a head in glass
when David eventually does have his
run-in with the Horde and sees the wrong
that he's committed in his past it'll be
interesting to see if he bumps into one
personality of the Horde if he's going
to see just that identities actions or
if he's gonna see stuff that the other
identities have done as well so here we
go it actually is gonna line up where
Kevin is at the train station at the
same time as David Dunn and I'm the
whole Train thing obviously it's not
like there aren't other films that have
trains in them you know even other
Shyamalan films that happening they take
a train to try to get out of the
Northeast area in the visit they take a
train to go visit the grandparents so I
think that's kind of something that
helps cover up the fact that split was a
single because you could say like oh
trains it's got to be related to
unbreakable but then you think oh now
there's been trains and plenty of homes
and it's not really until you take like
that deeper look at it that you realize
how some
they actually are so two girls locked up
inside a closet two girls locked up
inside separate closets and splits I
take that back this is actually a
bathroom that the girls an unbreakable
are locked up and I believe it looks
like David's fights with the orange man
is basically going to coincide with dr.
Fletcher's struggle against the Beast
and like structurally maybe it coincides
with Casey's fight with the Beast at the
end of split I'm gonna miss dr. Fletcher
and glass she's one of my favorite
characters and how about this doctor
Fletcher leaves that little note for the
girls and that's like she's reaching out
to the hero and giving them hell and on
an unbreakable you've got David he's
probably gonna drown in that swimming
pool if not with the help from the girls
who throw him the pole that helped him
get out which you can see on the left
right here and yeah I mean it's
something that happens a lot of the time
in comic books and comic book movies
where the heroes down and he seeks help
from some outside force some other good
guy know that this is crazy this is
crazy okay so Casey is gonna discover
Claire's dead body and just as David
goes to to try to help this girl the mom
and discovering that she's dead as well
and they're taking place at the exact
same point in both movies Oh what no
they opened the door in sync come on
that one's pretty funny
what could be shots they're like mirror
images of each other this was such a fun
experiment and I mean realistically
again like from a structural standpoint
him carrying the wife out and saying
like okay the nightmares over now is
basically like the equivalent of split
where the guy finds Kasey at the end
after the confrontation with the beast
and takes her out and gets her the help
that she needs
yeah so at this point I'm not sure that
there's gonna be anything else that
lines up because we're already past that
climax and unbreakable and we're kind of
just getting into it in split I'm like I
said split is a longer movie I think it
was just whole speech about not knowing
your place in the world kind of
coincides with the ending scene of split
which were obviously met yet they want
the world to know that they exist
all right so unbreakable is now over
split is just finishing up its climax
really so there are a lot of really
interesting things some of them
coincidence and some of them are scenes
that it kind of took the same purpose in
both films and took place at similar
spots but sometimes the exact same spot
and sometimes similar ratio into the
story I guess so that's gonna do it for
this video I'm probably gonna hang out
and finish watching the end of splits
but until next time when we're gonna be
doing a things you missed on glass
coming up later at the end of this week
I'm very much looking forward to that
I'm very much looking forward to seeing
glass so if you're interested in that
remember to subscribe to seize these
worlds for new Horrors every week ring
that
notifications and I'll see you in the
next one
assuming we both survived okay one more
thing the last line of each movie is mr.
glass I just wanted to add that